હ
[Musique]
autour du monde quelques irréductibles
marin naviguent encore sur des bateaux
aux formes inchangées depuis des
siècles en Nouvelle-Calédonie sur l'île
des Pins la famille dou est la dernière
à construire des pirogues à balencier
traditionnel
en Indonésie les Bougis sont l'un des
seuls peuples de l'archipel à maîtriser
la construction navale de leurs
ancêtres des marins des pêcheurs des
charpentiers qui font vivre des bateaux
d'hier et
[Musique]
d'aujourd'hui
au cœur du Pacifique au sud-est de la
Nouvelle-Calédonie l'île Despins
apparaît dans toute sa
[Musique]
splendeur un confetti d'à peine 150 km
Carr que l'on surnomme l'île la plus
proche du paradis
[Musique]
des plages de sable
fin une nature luxuriante et des
pirogues à balanciers fendent l'eau
turquoise des
[Musique]
lagons
jeanou peré est né dans l'une des h
tribus canaqu de lîle il appartient au
clan de la mer et il a besoin d'une
nouvelle pirogue ce matin il part avec
son oncle Joseph l'un des derniers à
connaître les secr de fabrication d'une
pirogue à balancer calédonienne on va
chercher un bo dans la forêt va la
pointeess de repérer un bois
pour construire une pirue avec
pour construire leurs embarcations les
insulaires prennent depuis toujours ce
qu'ils ont sous la main l'Î est couverte
d'une espèce de pain endémique les
arocaria que l'on appelle ici des pains
colonires on appelle pain colonire parce
qu'il monte comme une colonne il cherche
le soleil c'est pour ça qu'il monte en
l'air ça monte jusqu'à 50 m 100
m les ponur ils sortent il dépassent la
forêt la petite
[Musique]
forêt c'est à la vue de ces arbres
dressés vers le ciel que le capitaine
Cook célèbre explorateur anglais du 18e
siècle baptisa ce petit bout de terre
l'île des
pains
le groupe s'enfonce dans la forêt à la
recherche de l'arbre idéal pour la
pirogue on est juste en repérage là mais
c'est le c'est ch qui va dire si l'arme
le plît je veux lui dire que le diamètre
est bon ou il me sur Mettre à comme ça
maintenant s chois son arme je veux dire
après si c'est
bon
mais regardez là si c'est
bon c'est toi qui faire la pire allez
c'estess reg regard
noir
ah là je entain de regarder l' regarder
la grosseur si est droit ou il est un
peu
tordu si ça me convient ben je je le
prends là je préfère faire avec la p
colonire comme c'est plus c'est plus
facile puis on travaille vite le ce bois
est t comme
bois le pain colonnaire est utilisé pour
la coque de la pirogue mais dans la
forêt chaque essence a son
utilité on utilise l' bois voilà cel qui
le ye là parce qu'il est flexible il est
résistant cela prends pour les le M de
pirong et puis les traverses qui relie
le balancier à à la coque principale
celui-là c'est un faux ou on le prend
pour faire la charpente c'est un bois
qui a le cœur il est chenatre bien
chaude Jean aperçoit enfin un pain qui
lui
plaît je pense que cel il est
bonéresse le
bois la grosseur ça te va oui pas trop
gros pas trop petit c'est juste
ouais à 80 80
ok je juste marqué mon initial voilà
c'est pour que s'il y a quelqu'un qui
arrive il voit le pas il va pas couper
parce il y a mon initial à côté il va
trouver un
[Musique]
mais avant d'abattre son arbre Jean doit
faire la
coutume offrir un cadeau pour avoir
l'autorisation de couper le pain qui se
trouve sur les terres d'une autre
tribu pour les h tribus de l'île des
pains la tradition de la coutume est
immuable
obligatoire
c'est demander l'autorisation au vieux
pu donne l'autorisation d'aller dans la
forêt que la forêt pas permis à
tout com dans la
for respecteri la
nature aujourd'hui le présent est
symbolique un paquet de tabac un billet
et un bout de
tissu
ça
[Musique]
chaque étape de la construction de la
pirogue tient compte du cycle
lunaire bientôt la lune bientôt la lune
pour la bonne lune pour
[Musique]
couper les n'importe quoi C toujour
après la pleine
lune
descendu
la coutume ça ça un
atissement
si si je veux couper une pirogue
[Musique]
ou demander un bout de terrain sur un
c'est obligé qu'on fait qu'on fasse une
coute pour la tribu le clan la famille
voilà comme ça ils sont au courant de ce
qu'on fait c'est
important c'est parce que on n pas tout
seule dès demain Jean reviendra couper
son arbre la construction de sa nouvelle
pirogue pourra alors
commencer
[Musique]
à plus de 6000 km de la
Nouvelle-Calédonie proche de l'Australie
voici l'une des plus grandes îles de
l'archipel indonésien sous la
[Musique]
vie le petit village de tanaberou est
situé à l'extrême sud de
lî un village ou plutôt une age qui
abrite un chantier naval
[Musique]
exceptionnel ici sur 2 km sa ligne
descoqu en
construction ces grands voilier
d'inspiration pinisie permett au
navigateur indonésien dès le 19e siècle
de relier les 17000 îles de leur immense
archipel
depuis une cinquantaine d'années les
moteurs ont remplacé les voiles sur les
pinisies mais la forme pointue de l'tav
et caractéristique de ces bateaux de
tradition Bachir est l'un des meilleurs
charpentiers de pinisie de
tanabou il a construit la plupart des
bateaux de ce petit
port
ci nous sommes dans le port de pêche
traditionnel de
bag et le bateau que vous voyez là-bas
le bleu et blanc c'est ma dernière
construction il est FL
neu allez on va partir mais tu vas où
là tu vas où non on va juste tester le
bateau et on
[Musique]
revient ce matin il vient inspecter son
dernier
nez
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
avant de commencer à naviguer
il faut vraiment vérifier que les
machines à l'intérieur du bateau soi
dans un bon état et qu'ell soi prête à
démarrer dans le bateau nous avons de
moteurs le moteur de pilotage et celui
du filet de
remorquage c'est important de vérifier
que tous les deux soient bien
opérationnel Bir et son équipe vont
faire naviguer leur bateau pour la
première
fois
[Musique]
j'ai l'impression que ça va le moteur du
bas a de secousse que la dernière fois
oui c'est
[Musique]
vrai j'aime beaucoup être sur ces
bateaux pour apprécier l'assemblage fait
par les charpentiers de marine et voir
aussi que la forme du bateau est bien
respectée mais ce que j'apécie encore
plus quand le bateau est terminé pêche
soit bonne si mon bateau leur porte
chance les pêcheurs sont contents et
donc moi
aussi toutes les bases du métier je les
ai apprises de mes parents c'est un
enseignement qui se transmet de
génération en
génération je peux vous le dire je mets
tout mon cœur dans mes bateaux j'y suis
très
attaché dès que je me réveille ma
première pensée sera toujours de me
demander comment vont mes bateaux
kapal je su vraent heure quand je voisne
qu de faire un de
mainten pees parties qui ne sont pas
encore très
belles c'est important de passer une
dernière couche de
peinture ça permet de bien le
protéger ce n'est pas simplement
décoratif c'est vraiment pour la
protection du
bateau Bir n'a plus que quelques heures
pour achever son
ouvrage il va entamer dans la foulée la
construction d'un nouveau
[Musique]
pinisi retour sur l'île des Pins au
large de la nouvelle
[Musique]
calédonnie
près du village de vao au sud de lîle
voici la petite baie de Saint-Joseph
elle abrite des pirogues bien sûr mais
aussi le petit chantier naval de Joseph
dernier charpentier de marine de
[Musique]
lîle un chantier aux aires de vacances à
même la
plage une semaine après le repérage dans
la forêt le pain colonnaire de Jean est
déjà entre les mains expertes de
Joseph première étape de la construction
les vidage du Tron faut que vous mettez
un peu
leain comme ça pour avoir l'épaisseur de
bois normalement il faut
mettre 3 cm sur les côtés et au fond il
faut mettre une dizaine de
centimètres
[Musique]
chaque nouvelle construction de pirogue
se fait en
[Musique]
famille à chaque fois quand on passe
devant un vieux quand il travaille on
peut pas passer et puis passer tout
droit on va pas respire on doit
s'arrêter puis lui demander s'il a pas
besoin d'un coup de main
s'il a besoin de quelque chose pour
avancer son
travail comme on avait commenté la pyog
voilà ESS de travailler avec lui en même
temps à
prendre depuis 50 ans Joseph construit
des pirogues selon les mêmes techniques
ancestrales au fil du temps la ponceuse
a pourtant remplacé le rabot et le
charpentier a apporté sa touche de
modernité la technique a changé avec les
comment là les produit modernes
maintenant il y a la colle maintenant
l'étancherté à 100 % mais avant c'était
avec le les cores de goui ça fuyait de
tous les
bords il reste encore 15 jours de
travail à Joseph pour terminer cette
nouvelle
pirogue chaque année il en construit une
dizaine je pense pas que la la pyog va
partir parce qu'il y a les bate à mot au
contraire elle est en train de renître
enc les jeunes il se mettent à
construire les P avant il y Ava de trois
Py et maintenant il y a une diaine une
[Musique]
quinzaine c'est dans le sang quoi même
les enfants là c'est dans le
sang la PIR elle est unique àp il faut
la
garder c'est l'emblème de
P un emblème qui trouve son utilité au
quotidien sur l'île des pains on aime
pêcher en pirogue à
[Musique]
balancier
retour à tanaberou au nord-ouest de
[Musique]
l'Indonésie héritier d'une longue et
forte tradition maritime la moitié des
habitants travaillent dans la
construction
[Musique]
navale
pour Bachir le charpentier de marine la
voix était toute
tracée allez bonne journée travaille
bien à
l'école comme tous les matins il se rend
sur son lieu de travail le chantier
naval sous ce fouiller apparent et ses
échafaudages de fortune tout est
parfaitement organisé le savoir-faire
des bouies est réputé dans toute
l'Indonésie une cinquantaine
d'embarcations sort du chantier chaque
année tu peux m'aider installer
cette la planche s'il te
plaît
on a toujours utilisé ce genre d'outil
très simple c'est vraiment des outils
qu'on utilise depuis des
siècles c'est une tradition que nous
perpétuons
encore même si nous avons d'autres
outils il ne représente qu'un tiers de
notre
[Musique]
matériel
depuis toujours les charpentiers de
tanaberou construisent leur bateau sans
plan ni gabarit tout
see vasy doucement
doucement il n'y a pas de vis non plus
ni de boulon ni de clous tout est
assemblé avec des chevilles taillé dans
le même bois que les planches du
bateau
ce savoirfaire est un vrai patrimoine
propre à notre
région c'est vraiment un héritage qui
nous vient de nos
ancêtres que vous alliez en Indonésie si
vous voyez des bateau
comme la technique de fabrication vient
forcment
Abdul est le beau-père de Bachir il est
le plus expérimenté des artisans du
chantier en 40 ans il a participé à la
construction d'une centaine de
pinisis ça fait 3 semaines qu'on
travaille sur ce bateau et il nous
faudra encore 3 mois pour le
terminer ce savoir-faire nous a été
transmis par notre arrière arrière-
grand-père ça se transmet de père en
fils
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ce savoir-faire est reconnu
officiellement il y a quelques années je
travaillais sur un autre chantier à Java
une autre île de l'archipel l'ancien
Premier ministre pibi était venu nous
voir pour nous féliciter il a même
plaisanté en disant vous pourriez pas me
faire des avions
aussi
libuk
[Musique]
cepat
K
som t voisin ici nous sommes comme une
grande
famille mais il y a quand même une
certaine
organisation en dehors du chef de
chantier chacun a sa
spécialité c'est dans cette atmosphère
détendu que nous construisons no
bateau
[Musique]
le soir même toute l'équipe de Bachir se
retrouve autour d'un bateau de 21 m
qu'elle vient
d'achever les hommes placent
l'embarcation sur des rondins pour
pouvoir la glisser facilement jusqu'à
l'eau le jour du lancement une opération
[Musique]
délicate
là faudrait peut-être changer de côté
non change de côté
maintenant change de
côté
pour commencer la mise à l'eau on doit
choisir un jour qui
convient parce que tous les jours ne
sont pas forcément adéqu surtout pour
les bateaux de pêche c'est pour nous
laisser un maximum de chance d'attraper
des
[Musique]
poissons ce bateau traditionnel n'est
pas un simple gagneepain pour Bachir et
les autres
artisans c'est un objet précieux qu'il
remett alors à une autre Corporation du
village
[Musique]
pêcheurs petit matin sur la baie dupi
une des plus belles de l'île des
Pins cette petite mer intérieure est
parsemée de rochers coraliens comme posé
à la surface de
l'eau
c'est ici que Jean et les siens viennent
pêcher le
mulet chez les canques la pêche est
presque exclusivement une histoire
d'homme Jean navigue avec Joseph
Alexandre son frère et son jeune neveu
tous appartiennent au clan de la
[Musique]
mer parceelle au ave les canotes on
peut il y a de
l'espace tandis qu'un bateau moteur
c'est tout rfermé à chaque fois faut
lever le filet pour chter pardessus bord
alors que là on faitfiler le filet c'est
fait tout s TR
forcer pour ces pêcheurs au regard
aiguisé il faut d'abord repérer le ban
de poisson
fautireite faut faire vite en
directionon qui sa là on dirait sont
descendus
là on VO la
poussière c'est un
peu ça se dépl le
poisson ILT vu
un descendre la voile puis on va essayer
de les attraper quelquesin pour mancher
ce
[Musique]
soir une fois le banc de poisson repéré
il faut agir
[Musique]
vite à l'arrière de la pirogue Joseph et
Abel déroul un filet de 100 m de
long pour les rabats bre dans le filet
la technique est imparable il suffit de
faire du bruit
j'attain de taper l'eau pour faire fuire
le poisson puis dans le
[Musique]
filetou va vers le Malis c'est Notre
culture c'est la tradition
quoi il faut que ça se
perpétue il faut que ça vive en
fait ce que
j'apprécie ici à des
c'est des moments avec sa famille moment
de
partage avec de de car de car alors
Julien alors c'est alors aujourd'hui la
pêche se résume à une dizaine de
poissons seulement qui se sont laissés
piéger ah il y a tou ch et oui il est là
plus c'est le B
F d'abord on pêche pour la famille s'il
y a pe de TR on Essie deend dans les hôs
dans
les
magasin
poisson ça qu'on fait ici dans notreb
dans le on est des
pêcheurs on pratique la pche presque
tout le temps quoi ça
c'est
j'apprécie tous les moments
qu quand on est en P séchange sur les
PIR
les don des connaissances que voilà nous
on garde bien au fond de nous pour que
plus tard quand il seront plus
là on essaie de faire la
[Musique]
suiteo
la p c'est moyen de loomotion c'est on
fait tout sur une
P il y a la
pêche le tourisme il y a les travail
d'aller couper les bois dans les forêts
on met les poteau
[Musique]
tout
en fin de journée la famille a pour
habitude de s'arrêter sur une petite
plage pour
bivoquer et c'est
parti moment pour se reposer un peu
prendre la
force comme une PIR c'est lour c'est pas
comme un bateau titolé comme ça c'est
lourd comme pour percher pour faire les
manuvres on est tous fatigués faut bien
qu'on arrive comme ça là fait un petit
feu BR
poisson
grand je travaillé tout le temps
ici pris l'habitude quoi si vous restez
de jours à T vous
s'ennu aller en mer pu faire un coup de
P
revenir j'ai 70 ans
ouais peut-être c'est la dernière
année c'est le dernier coup de P
comme dit le vieux c'est
notre on fait pas le l'agriculture mais
on faê c'est notre champ notre champ
c'est la mer
voyez il a des moments où quand il y a
vraiment pas de poisson on est obligé de
rester jusqu'à au moins qu'on attrape
quelqu quelques poissons pour pou
rentrer à la
maison ce si on rentre brendou à la
maison ben tous
les vien de la maison ils vont nous ils
vont se moquer de nous parce qu'on est
rentré bredouille
quoi faut tours rentrer avec un truc à
la maison un poisson ou un CRAM ou un
truc pour mangcher le
soir c'est un moment qu'on apprécie
beaucoup le
feu discuter un peu au feu moich le
poisson la pêche en pirogue le bivoac au
bord de l'eau prendre son temps c'est un
art de vivre que les Canaques de l'île
des Pins ne sont pas prêt
[Musique]
d'abandonner le jour se lève à peine sur
le petit port de tanabou en Indonésie
c'est le airlang qui le premier prend la
mer un bateau de 25 m de long qui a bien
sûr été construit par
Bachir h pêcheurs ont pris place à bord
comme toujours ils partent pour la
journée
warudi fait partie des ancien son poste
est essentiel avec TR autres pêcheurs il
observe la surface de l'eau et sans
relâche les B de
poisson comme tous les pinis ce bateau
possède un petit m qui sert de
Vig nous avonseruelques poiss de loin se
f i pour
obsver quelque fois ils surgissent hors
de l'eau donc c'est plus facile pour
nous on a juste à les encercler avec le
filet ici dans cette mer on attrape
principalement du Merlan de la bonite et
des
enchois ce genre de bateau est vraiment
idéal pour la pêche au
filet là-bas un ban de
[Musique]
poisson aussitôt le bateau makeup sur le
banc de
poisson arrivés sur place les pêcheurs
déroulent un immense filet de 500 m de
long et de 40 m de
profondeur le bateau commence sa
manœuvre
d'encerclement
on a aperçu des poissons dans cette zone
et on s'est dépêché pour arriver on
espère vraiment qu'ils se sont accroché
au
filet chaque lâché de filet est Inc
parfois les efforts ne
pas dépêche-toi un peu allez un peu de n
allez
[Musique]
vas-y nombreux pour remonter le filet
car il est très
lourd la première tentative est un échec
ils sont arrivés trop tard pas un seul
poisson ne s'est pris dans le
filet les pêcheurs vont tenter leur
chance plus
[Musique]
loin ils ne peuvent pas se permettre de
revenir
[Musique]
brodouille salamoun est le capitaine du
bateau la pêche la construction de
bateau ce sont nos métiers
ici c'est notre seul moyen de
subsistance il n'y a qu'une petite
centaine de pêcheurs aujourd'hui qui
continuent d'utiliser des can à pêches
ordinaires INRA est le plus jeune à bord
il a à peine 17
ans quand j'étais petit je partais déjà
en mer avec mon père c'est comme ça que
j'ai tout appris
[Musique]
Lain là-bas un ban de poisson on a
trouvé du
[Musique]
poisson
après 3 He d'effort intense les pêcheurs
remontent enfin quelques poissons dans
leur
filet pêche moyenne mais c'est suffisant
alors les gars la pêche a ét bonne on
s'arrête pas tant qu'on a pas atteint
les 5 millions de
poissons alors que l'autre équipage
persévère salamoun le capitaine décide
de rentrer au port de
tanabou ils vont réserver ces quelques
poissons à leur famille en espérant que
la journée du lendemain sera
meilleure j'espère qu'on arriver àmre
àants façon de pêcher le poisson de
lancer le filet de pêche et puis tout
simplement de réussir à vivre de ce
[Musique]
métier
en Nouvelle-Calédonie sur l'île des
pains les femmes cultivent les champs
pendant que les hommes
[Musique]
pêchent ils sont tout le temps en champ
les
femmes et les sommes il ils sont au
champ aussi mais les sommes de comme je
suis marié à avec un pêcheur il est
toujours à la mer il MTE mais son
univers c'est la mer aujourd'hui Sabine
la tante de gens va préparer un bouia un
plat de fête Canac souvent à base de
poisson récupère la tubercule de de
manioc on va s' servir pour le
Bou sabine est venue chercher l'ignam
l'ingrédient essentiel à la préparation
du plat traditionnel Canac voilà l'ignam
m qu'on a
planté
l'ignnam c'est notre
culture euh sans lignam on n'est pas on
ne on n'est pas un
Canac celui qui a un chantignam c'est
et dans un notre coutume il est grand
allez tiens viens là comme ça tu bien la
tenir parce que voilà voilà la deuxème
étape il faut aller chercher les
feuilles de
Banani pour un bou il faut 5 feuill de
banane voilà les signames la citrouille
magnoc
et banane voilà pour un bouant il faut C
cocos c'est hyper important pour que
votre B soit réussi sec
coco je suis en train deplucher les
signam les
[Musique]
bananes toute la famille met la main à
la pâte c'est l'eau la préparation d'un
Bignon il va rester que le poisson
poisson frais j'ai ce
matin on va presser le
coco on pre direct
ded faut que le Bou soit
bien bien noyer tout ça dans le lait de
coco refermer le Bou
voilà feuille par feuille oui feuille
par
feuille et voilà lui
ok allez on va poser ça à côté le
four dans le four oui allez venez tout
le monde venez parce queil faut tu CR la
cocon tu peux l'osser là là ça à côté
les feuilles là
oui dernière étape de la préparation du
Bouat
la
[Musique]
cuisson ça c'est le four
can chauffer en blanc les
[Musique]
cailloux après on recouvre de feuilles
et on va les
recouvrir de terre
aprè et c'est parti pour 2 he de cuisson
sous la
venez les garçons vaterer le
[Musique]
Bou ça sent bon
là bon le
petit alors c'est pas beau ça bon
appétit tout le
monde le lendemain à l'aube Jean est à
nouveau sur sa pirogue une nouvelle
journée de pêche commence dans le
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
lagon
la famille doupéré est la gardienne des
traditions du clan de la mer de l'île
des pains à bord de sa pirogue semblable
à celle de ses ancêtres Jean compte bien
les ancrés dans le présent et dans
[Musique]
l'avenir tabou en Indonésie une fête se
prépare Akba un pêcheur vient d'acheter
son premier bateau pinisi pour la somme
de 4000
€ sa famille organise une grande
cérémonie avant la première sortie en
mer toutes les femmes sont à pied
d'œuvre pour préparer les
festivités
[Musique]
on prépare des hondond pour la cérémonie
de ce
soir ce sont des boules de farine de r
gluant avec un morceau de caramel à
l'intérieur et de la noix de coco
autour
même les enfants nous aident à préparer
le repas de ce
soir il y a pas ass de noix de coco
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
maman la première fois la femme du
propriétaire et ses cousines sont
autorisé à monter sur le nouveau
[Musique]
bateauanabou une croyance dit que les
femmes portent malheur sur un chantier
naval mais elles sont les bienvenu une
fois le bateau à
[Musique]
l'eau
allez arrêtez les enfants c'est pas le
moment on fait cette cérémonie pour que
tout se passe bien en mer et aussi pour
les
employés
[Musique]
a fait venir les TR imams du village
pour bénir son
[Musique]
bateau ce bateau est tout
nouveau comm un hab qu'on présente à
tout
fait à
[Musique]
vill et cette ens qu'on
diffuse est censé nous apporter de la
[Musique]
chance c'est important de bénir les
bateaux mais c'est valable également
pour l'inauguration d'une
maison la fin des récoltes de riz ou de
maïs par exemple
akukan
Biasa bangavir
bateau
allahon dari
[Musique]
keluarga
je bénis aussi cette
machine pour qu'elle ne se chauffe
[Musique]
pas
c'est vraiment important de perpétuer
ces
cérémonies parce que ça nous vient de
nos
ancêtres mais ce qui est encore plus
important c'est de perpétuer la
tradition des chantiers naval de
tanabou
[Musique]
dans un monde en perpétuel mouvement ces
bateaux sont un trait d'union entre hier
et aujourd'hui entre tradition et
modernité utilisé au quotidien c'est un
patrimoine vivant qui a encore de beaux
jours devant
[Musique]
lui